seront vus au zimbabwe en nouvelle
zélande ou en alaska et la martinique
sera vu à ce moment
il faisant partie de l'est du var et de
la yole qui avait fait venir des
skippers français sur des yeux il ya
quelques années l'organisation m'a
demandé de faire partie de défraiement
de l'association est d'apporter ma
modeste contribution à l'effort pour
faire venir en martinique une super
honnête je suis excité parce que nous
avons les plus beaux gâteaux du monde
les bateaux les plus rapides ici les
meilleurs skippers donc on ne peut
prenez l'exemple tout à l'heure c'est
comme si vous dites en des gens qui font
la course automobile a bien donné il ya
un mille tonnes qui vient c'est à peu
près ça pou situer ce que c'est ça veut
dire que la martinique à cette
opportunité extraordinaire d'accueillir
tous ces grands skippers avec bien sûr
souvent les comités d'entreprise les
conseils d'administration de ces grandes
boîtes qui financent ces bateaux et qui
vont vivre la sémantique est bouté à nos
produits c'est bon vous l'économie c'est
mon rôle touristes que nous mettions nos
produits en valeur alors faire savoir
que la martinique existe
il y à un martiniquais authentique eric
barret et puis vous avez une et aux
martiniquais je dirais marie tabarly qui
est la fille d'éric tabarly les dans la
mairie martiniquaise et puis à clément j
gros qui est aussi dans la classe imoca
avec l'ema giro il est né à martigues
c'est une manifestation pour les parties
sous tous ses aspects devraient être
bénéfiques à lamartine nous avons cette
source extraordinaire il faut la saisir